c'est parti pour 30 minutes de cuisson
nous ne sommes pas dans une boulangerie
mais dans l'atelier d'un artisan
chocolatier cédric turmel pâtissier de
formation est tombé amoureux du chocolat
dès son plus jeune âge
installé à gars lui ses créations
gourmandes sont exposées dans son
showroom
elles ont toutes une particularité la
matière première qu'ils utilisent et
certifiés bio j'ai choisi de travailler
que le bio parce que dans ma vie privée
je fais attention à tout ce que je mange
et je me suis dit ben on va être en
adéquation avec les avec nos clients
étant donné que je ne fais que des
petites quantités
je peux me permettre de faire de faire
du bio cédric turmel travail en direct
avec des producteurs de madagascar
d'équateur ou encore du pérou les fèves
de cacao sont ensuite transformés dans
son atelier
le chocolatier préfère miser sur la
qualité plutôt que la quantité
dans sa boutique et depuis peu sur son
site internet vous trouverez
essentiellement des mini tablettes
fourrées au praliné ou au caramel fleur
de sel et durant le mois de janvier des
galettes à la frangipane alors la
proteam pana vo vous éclater le reste
c'est pas la frangipane qui au chocolat
et on dise de fèves cédric turmel a
souhaité rester dans l'univers qu'il
affectionne